décimo quinto día de huelga y las
basuras siguen transformando las calles
de París en pasillos estrechos y
malolientes
en París a pesar de las requisiciones
las recolecciones siguen atrasadas y las
montañas de basura obligan a los
comerciantes a organizarse para reducir
las molestias como pueden escondemos las
basuras porque es asqueroso para los
clientes
algunos tomaron iniciativas como este
farmacéutico el miércoles pasado llamó a
una sociedad de recolección privada
porque la puerta de su tienda estaba
llena de basura
era más o menos de dos metros de altura
hasta aquí
un servicio que le costó alrededor de
500 euros y dice que los pagaría otra
vez si es necesario
y todos los días Esperamos que los
recolectores pasen y si no llegan
Tendremos que llamar otra vez a esta
sociedad privada y una tercera vez y así
sucesivamente desde el jueves algunos
recolectores Se recibieron órdenes de
adelantar las labores pero las colectas
siguen siendo limitadas algunas
incineradoras siguen bloquea como la de
Y si le murió esta mañana solo un camión
podía entrar cada 15 minutos
este conductor tuvo que irse sin haber
podido Descargar
la mano ahora dónde va
regreso al garaje de free el camión
lleno
algunos vehículos salieron del depósito
pero regresaron sin recoger ni un solo
residuo se necesitarían tres días
completos de recolección a toda
velocidad para lograr evacuar las más de
9000 toneladas de basura que se acumulan
en las calles de París esta mañana en
algunas ciudades como León varios
recolectores también se unieron al
movimiento